[SOUND]
[LAUGH]
>> Okay Brad, you got this.
Karen, you got your power post its, you
got your blue bottled coffee just don't
spill it on Marc Benioff or
you're getting fired.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Hi everyone.
I am Brad Hungerman.
I am the new product manager
here at Salesforce and
I'm just really excited today to be
talking to you about some of the different
customer features that we've been
studying for the last few months.
We came up with some really good
ideas that I want to share with you.
And so let me just throw a couple
of stats up on the board here.
>> What's going on?
What's going on here?
>> Is this guy joking?
>> I don't have time for this.
>> Should we talk to his?
>> Now why is he speaking here?
>> Why is he so nervous?
>> Guys, I have to go.
>> Well, well,
I can't remember the exact statistics but
the really important
thing that I want you to.
Where'd everyone go?
>> [LAUGH]
>> So I want to ask you,
what did Brad do wrong here?
Anyone?
Stephanie?
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> You got it right.
He was very nervous and it really show.
His body language was all off.
He was touching his neck and his hair,
which signifies nervousness.
He was holding a cup in front of him,
which puts a physical barrier between
him and his audience, and
he was just not doing well.
So today, we're going to talk
to you about how to rock your
next presentation with body language.
The agenda for today is explaining to
you why body language is crucial for
your next presentation.
Giving you four tips of body language
you can use, and then telling you
a story about an entrepreneur who use
body language to build his business.
Now we're all in this class and
we've become better presenters.
But we don't know, sorry.
So 93% of communication is non verbal,
and that's why it's so important.
And 50% of it,
is actually body language alone.
And all of you will
present in your next job.
Well you might think you might be able to
wiggle out of it, but that's not true.
Stephanie, you're going
into growth equity,
so you're going to present investment
opportunities to your partners.
Reed, you're going into consulting,
you'll need to present to clients as
a way to move up in your organization.
We'll have to do it.
Now, I want to turn off your brains, and
turn two parts on because we're
going to talk about statistics.
>> [LAUGH]
>> 70% of Americans believe that
presentation skills are crucial for
career success.
And when senior executives have
been surveyed in the past,
they've said that executive presence
accounts of 26% of what it takes to get
promoted to the next level.
That's a fourth of what
it takes to get promoted.
I'm not sure how much
performance actually is, so
maybe Jeff Pfeffer was right after all.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So now,
I'm going to turn it over to Paul who
will give you some tips on body language.
>> We've spent all week
in the acronym factory.
We've thought about lots
of permutations of letters.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And we've come up with four
that you need to remember-
>> [LAUGH]
>> For you to walk out of this
room a better non verbal communicator.
My friends, I present today,
the AWSM method.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It's going to require a little bit of
memory on your part.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Because A stands for
approach your audience
with an eyebrow flash.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But this is actually very serious.
And I was astonished when I did the
research, that the top half of your face
is seen as more authentic that
your bottom half of your face.
People perceive that the area around
your mouth is easily manipulable.
And that what you're doing with your
mouth isn't necessarily trustworthy.
When you emote with the top of your face,
when you raise your eyebrows,
when you show interest,
when you light up your eyes,
people feel a connection
coming out of that.
They feel closer to you and they feel
more of an engagement with your content.
So when you walk into a room
to give a presentation,
some of the tips we've learned earlier
in the class are important too.
Pause, scan the room,
don't rush into whatever you're saying,
but also raise your eyes,
engage with your audience,
and use the top half of
your face in this way.
The next part of the AWSM framework,
it doesn't have to be, by the way.
>> [LAUGH]
>> A Jim Carey eyebrow flash.
The next part of the AWSM framework
is to win with the right smile.
And this is really important
because smiling is contagious.
When you smile like Nisha is right now,
it makes the rest of the room happier,
it makes people more engaged and
it makes people feel more
confident in what you're saying.
Smiling, especially when
you're smile authentically and
not a kind of forced teeth grin.
Smiling gives you more confidence
in what you're saying.
It releases endorphins in your
body that makes you feel stronger,
makes you feel more confident,
makes you feel more powerful.
Walk into a room, pause, scan the room,
raise your eyes, smile.
It's all going to help you connect better
with your audience, build more confidence
in your presentation and ultimately get
the results that you're hoping for.
Brad's got the next two
parts of the AWSM framework.
>> Now, Paul has just shared with you
a couple of important techniques to make
sure that your facial expressions are
really demonstrating the confidence and
competence that you want to convey
in your next big presentation.
What I want to do is I
want to switch gears and
talk about the lower parts of your body
and how to use them effectively as well.
Starting with your hands.
Now the next part in our
AWSM framework is s.
Steepling with confidence.
Just like Angela here she
does a pretty good job of it.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But you don't want to look like Angela
is right now permanently
with your hands steepled.
I don't know if you noticed it but
Leo in the presentation just a few
minutes ago was steepling like a pro.
>> [LAUGH]
>> He did it just enough to look confident
and to point emphasis on his points and
that's exactly what you
want to use steepling for.
You just don't want to do it for
the sake of doing it.
Do it with a purpose and
so just sparingly.
Now when you're not steepling,
you have a few other techniques
that you can draw from as well.
And they all have to do
with open palm gestures.
And you might not want to do exactly that,
because that looks a little defensive, and
this looks like you're asking for
something.
But this is another way to
demonstrate emphasis and
confidence without the aggression
of pointing at someone.
One of my bad habits.
Now you can also double it up and
use two hands to double your emphasis,
both good techniques.
And lastly, the M in our AWSM framework
stands for moving to keep your audience's
attention or if you can't remember that,
moving like JD does in his presentations.
So there's really two techniques that
you're going to want to remember.
When to move forward and
when to move back.
When you're moving forward, that's when
you're going to want to emphasize a point.
Ijiku, I might even couple it up with some
steepling to really emphasize my point.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But when I'm done talking with you,
I'm going to break and
pause and move back.
And that's going to be a natural
change to a different topic.
>> How many of you have heard about this?
The Humans of New York?
So I don't have to explain.
This is Brandon Stenton,
the end guy in the cap.
What he does is every morning he takes his
camera and he walks up to a stranger and
then asks his or
her permission to take the photograph.
And then engages in
a conversation with that person.
Let's for a moment assume that you're all
strangers here, and I'm Brandon Stenton.
I walk like this, look at
the strangers and take out the camera.
And ask the person, do you mind
if I take a photograph of your?
>> No, please take this.
>> [LAUGH]
>> This is the challenge what Brandon
faces every day.
In a split second, he has to build
a trust and confidence with a stranger.
First, to get the consent
to take the photograph.
Second, to engaging the conversation,
that actually builds a story for him.
And he has done tens of
thousands of these interviews.
And he has experimented
with multiple things.
The script, for example.
Using the word photograph
versus using the word portrait.
A hundred times, he has done it.
But the interesting
conclusion that he's come to,
is that the script doesn't matter.
All that matters is the body language.
The trust and the relaxation and
the confidence that you convey
in the body language,
is that matters at the end of it.
So this is a great story and
we spoke about body language today.
We heard about accent bias, we heard
about talking in a second language.
So if you think those biases exist,
use the body language aids,
and we gave you a great model today,
the AWSM model.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So with that,
we're all going to come out and
we'd love to take some questions and talk
to you more about non verbal communication
and how we can all be pros at it.
[MUSIC]